bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir
raconte mieux que personne les coulisses
du pouvoir bonsoir ludovican l'excellent
journaliste de l'opinion vous signez les
100 jours les 100 jours sa ns bien sûr
c'est chez bouquin c'est le livre qu'il
faut lire pour comprendre le passage à
vide d'Emmanuel Macron après sa
réélection pourquoi tout lui échappe
alors qu'il entre dans l'histoire c'est
un livre qui résonne aussi avec les 100
jours que le président s'est donné pour
redresser son quinquennat on va en
parler longuement tout à l'heure mais on
commence ce soir par ces deux mots
planification écologique Elisabeth borne
a repris possession du dossier hier elle
présentait les efforts à fournir pour
réduire de moitié nos émissions d'ici à
2030 mais qui dit transitions dit aussi
adaptation le mot n'est plus tabou
adaptation à une France de plus 4 degrés
de réchauffement d'ici à 2100 alors à
quoi ça peut ressembler et est-ce que
chacun est prêt à prendre sa part grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités
sur ce plateau avant de retrouver nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu ce
soir vous me suivez Ludovic ça vous
regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
une France a plus 4 degrés en 2100 le
gouvernement n'exclut plus un tel
scénario même si c'est le plus
pessimiste alors comment s'adapter
qu'est-ce qui va changer dans nos vies
au quotidien adaptation mais aussi
atténuation du réchauffement le partage
des efforts à fournir pour réduire nos
émissions a été arbitré hier par
Elisabeth borne bonsoir pierre Cazeneuve
et merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine et
membres de la commission du
développement durable vous débattez ce
soir avec votre collègue Lisa belluco
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue député
Europe Écologie Les Verts de la Vienne
et vice-présidente de cette même
commission développement durable à
l'Assemblée bonsoir Marc le Mazzi ravi
de vous retrouver vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste écologie et climat auteur de
France 2050 chez Albin Michel RCP 8.5
c'est le scénario noir du climat sur
lequel vous nous alerter si rien n'est
fait enfin bonsoir François Régis rod et
bienvenue économiste on viendra
évidemment avec vous sur le financement
de cette transition climatique que le
gouvernement souhaitait équitable Jean
Pisani ferry un grand économiste a fait
une proposition dans le débat public
Ludovic vigogne et bien sentez-vous
libre d'intervenir quand vous voulez
pour interroger pour réagir comme
citoyen comme journaliste politique
également dans ce débat on va commencer
par la méthode la démarche du
gouvernement adaptation d'un côté
limitation du réchauffement de l'autre
il a deux secondes pour nous détailler
les plans Béchu et bornes et c'est un
défi le chrono de Blacko tout de suite
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Myriam bon
j'espère que vous êtes en forme
c'est pas une mince affaire
que vous connaissez la différence entre
la théorie et la pratique il y a plein
d'exemples pour illustrer ça mais
puisqu'on parle le réchauffement on va
dire que la théorie c'est l'accord de
Paris signé en 2015 qui prévoit une
augmentation d'un degré et demi la
température moyenne sur la planète d'ici
2100 sauf que la pratique vu que
l'accord de Paris est très mal respecté
ça serait plutôt qu'on est parti sur une
hausse de 3 degrés en moyenne pour la
planète en 2016 qui en France
correspondrait en hausse de 4 degrés
voilà donc que le gouvernement décide de
ne plus faire l'autruche et donc
Christophe Béchu qui est mise de la
transition écologique dans une
consultation pour essayer que mon
pouvoir anticiper un petit peu les
conséquences de ce réchauffement plus
fort que prévu alors c'est vrai que si
je fais un petit bulletin météo du
climat 2050 vous allez voir que personne
n'était épargné même dans le Nord vous
voyez il y a des é sur le rivage des
inondations ce qui est d'ailleurs la
même chose dans le sud vous voyez
l'érosion inondations avec en plus dans
le sud sécheresse et feux de forêt les
hausses de température sont forcément un
peu plus fortes
loin de la mer mais on voit aussi des
îlots de chaleur dans les villes un peu
partout en France ou ajouter la neige
qui se transforme en puissance sur les
montagnes non jetaient plus ils restent
encore les grandes crues sur les fleuves
de France donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
consulter tout le monde même au niveau
local comment réagir à ce qui s'annonce
et donc ce matin Christophe des chutes
donné quelques exemples de ce qu'on
pourrait chercher anticiper
dans une France où on a des pics de
température à 50 degrés ce que nos
infrastructures de transport nos réseaux
de télécommunications sont assez
résilients est-ce que le nombre de
kilomètres de voies susceptibles d'être
submergé ou touché par l'érosion du
trait de côte doit pas être anticipé
est-ce que les conséquences d'éboulement
liées au risque en montagne ou en
outre-mer avec les cyclones doivent pas
être pris d'une manière différente
alors évidemment vu que gouverner c'est
prévoir on peut pas reprocher au
gouvernement enfin j'imagine qu'on ne
peut pas lui reprocher de tenir compte
des prédictions plutôt pessimistes du
GIEC que de l'optimisme initial de
l'accord de Paris enfin ça pourrait
aussi passer pour une forme de
défaitisme sur le thème de toute façon
puisqu'on atteindra jamais l'objectif de
Paris à quoi bon faire des efforts la
réponse du ministre ce que je veux dire
de la façon la plus claire qui soit
c'est en aucun cas ça n'est du
défaitisme ou du renoncement
l'engagement l'ambition c'est de baisser
nos émissions et de tenir nos
engagements climatiques et donc de
doubler notre rythme de baisse des
émissions alors de fait ça c'est l'autre
bande-annonce du gouvernement celle dont
vous avez parlé le plan de réduction des
gaz à effet de serre annoncés par
Isabelle bande donc ça avise des
objectifs 2030 c'est un très gros effort
qui nous est demandé parce qu'en fait on
doit diviser de moitié entre 90 et 2030
mais là regardez en 30 ans l'effort
qu'on a accompli depuis 90 c'est de
réduire de 25% les émissions de CO2 là
en 8 ans on nous demande de faire un
effort pour réduire de 1/3 donc 33% les
émissions de CO2 donc se pose évidemment
un peu la question de savoir qui va être
le premier concerné donc dans la
planification on a commencé par aborder
les questions par secteur économique
donc voilà ce que ça donne quels sont
les secteurs à qui on va demander le
plus d'efforts le bâtiment en premier
lieu peut-être que c'est là où il y a le
plus d'efforts à faire mais ça concerne
le logement vous voyez que petit à petit
d'autres seront un peu moins impactés
en proportion par exemple le transport
c'est vous qu'on va leur absolue un peu
moins proportion et les agriculteurs a
priori un peu préservés je vous laisse
débattre en vous rappelant que ce plan
et donc parfait mais que c'est une
théorie qui parfois entre la théorie la
pratique je voulais dire au début tu
vois un petit peu je crois que vous avez
marqué le point sur la conclusion de ce
billet merci beaucoup Stéphane c'est
vrai que ça donne un peu le vertige
pierre Cazeneuve quand on voit que la
marche a franchir et si haute alors on
n'a pas les mesures concrètes de
financement et d'accompagnement ce sera
pour juin si je comprends bien mais à ce
stade est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques éléments qui nous permettent de
penser qu'on peut aboutir à ses
objectifs chiffrés
alors je pense que déjà le plus
important c'est qu'on s'accorde sur le
constat et sur l'objectif qu'on s'est
fixé c'est à dire divisé par deux nos
émissions d'ici 2030 et un peu plus loin
mais c'est quand même ça le véritable
objectif qui est la neutralité carbone
en 2050 derrière ça peut paraître
anecdotique ou théorique mais l'objectif
de cette planification et quelque chose
d'extraordinairement compliqué et donc
tout le travail qui a été commencé
maintenant il y a un an c'est détailler
point par point secteur par secteur
parfois entreprises par entreprise les
émissions concrètement parce que il y a
une cellule planification à Matignon
puisque Elizabeth borne est aussi
ministre de la planification écologique
comment ça se détermine par qui on parle
des technovaires de Matignon
très fort du président de la République
pendant sa campagne pour son second tour
pour son second mandat pardon avec cet
engagement du discours de Marseille de
dire la première ministre sera en charge
directement de la planification déjà en
termes de considération de l'écologie
dans ce que ça représente aujourd'hui
dans la politique publique menée par la
France est extrêmement important c'est
certes symbolique mais c'est extrêmement
important et donc évidemment cette
première ministre elle est en charge
cette planification avec deux grands
ministres de tutelle l'un sur la
transition écologique l'autre sur la
transition énergétique et avec derrière
la création de ce qu'on appelle un
secrétaire général à la planification
écologique désolé c'est un peu tout ça
est un peu technique mais c'est
extrêmement important qui lui est en
charge vraiment de ce pilotage très
granulaire très opérationnel de cette
planification et tout son travail sur
cette première année a d'abord été de
cartographier qui produit quoi comme
émission de carbone parce que notre
ennemi commun c'est le carbone et de
cette dans la une fois qu'on sera
d'accord sur ce constat une fois qu'on
aura une vision extrêmement claire de la
cartographie carbone de la France
quelles sont les mesures nécessaires
pour
ces secteur là quels moyens financier
humain doit-on mettre en place pour y
arriver et donc c'est évidemment des
efforts de sobriété c'est à dire
consommer moins d'énergie c'est
évidemment des efforts de d'efficacité
énergétique aussi c'est-à-dire mieux
utiliser l'énergie que l'on consomme il
y a évidemment notre transition là aussi
énergétique donc électrifier nos usages
parce que ça produit moins d'émissions
et tout le travail encore une fois vous
comprenez que ce qui nous regardent qui
savent qu'il faut déjà financer
l'hôpital les services publics la
défense en ce moment à l'Assemblée 413
milliards se disent mais comment on peut
être optimiste face au mur
d'investissement qu'il va falloir faire
alors plusieurs réponses on attaque sur
le financement
sur le comment après mais déjà sur voilà
tous les pays européens doivent faire ça
en France on en est capable aussi bien
sûr qu'on en est capable déjà parce
qu'on est une économie
milliards de dettes mais une économie
qui est solide qui a su résister aux
différentes crises de ces dernières
années avec un taux de chômage plus
faible avec une stratégie de
réindustrialisation qui commence à
porter ses fruits donc la France on a de
la chance est une économie très solide
en ce moment et qui continue à
s'améliorer donc on va dire oui
aujourd'hui on a la capacité derrière on
a un pays qui évidemment en et c'est
impossible de découpler la dette
publique financière de la dette
climatique moi j'ai toujours j'ai 28 ans
je suis élu député depuis 11 mois je
suis arrivé dans ce mandat avec 3000
milliards de dettes et deux et demi
trajectoires 3 degrés d'ici 2050 donc ça
c'est la dette qu'on laisse et
aujourd'hui maintenant il faut
absolument qu'on trouve les moyens pour
investir massivement dans cette
transition énergétique ça passe à la
fois par les investissements de l'État
ça passe évidemment par des
investissements du secteur privé des
entreprises un lien très fort avec les
collectivités territoriales parce qu'ils
sont responsables de 75% de la course
optimiste bien sûr qu'on optimiste
donc il y a une forme d'optimiste là
dessus quand on est face au mur
finalement on n'a pas le choix que de
décaisser ses investissements pour pour
y arriver les amis que ça fait longtemps
qu'on entend ce mot planification sur
les rangs de l'opposition mais ça y est
c'est un mot qui prend une certaine
forme concrète au gouvernement on
attendait les objectifs chiffrés
secteurs par secteur qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez c'est un tournant dans la
démarche au moins
sur l'adaptation c'est c'est nouveau là
aussi non c'est un vrai revirement enfin
je sais pas si c'est le bon terme mais
enfin
c'est important de dire que il va
falloir s'adapter et j'apprécie le
propos du ministre BECHU qui dit ce
n'est pas un renoncement il faut
absolument tout faire et je le redis il
faut absolument tout faire pour
atteindre nos objectifs de réduction de
nos émissions de GES de gaz à effet de
serre pardon mais néanmoins il faut
aussi être prêt à s'adapter et ça veut
dire ça veut pas juste dire on va isoler
nos maisons du show enfin ça veut dire
que il y a peut-être des zones en France
qui lancent des artificielles si on est
sur cette trajectoire à leur donner une
idée les exemples concrets et bah
aujourd'hui là ce qui va changer par
exemple on le voit sur le pourtour
méditerranéen aujourd'hui on a plus
d'eau ça ça pourrait être récurrent
aujourd'hui là on est dans une année
exceptionnelle c'est une année
exceptionnelle qui risque de se
reproduire donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec l'agriculture sur le pourtour
méditerranéen et ce qu'on choisit de
faire autre chose à cet endroit là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec la montée de
la montée de la mer il y a des il y a
des maisons qui vont disparaître il y a
des littoraux qui vont reculer mais
drastiquement ça veut dire qu'il y aura
des gens reloger ça veut dire qu'il y
aura plus de tempêtes aussi tout ça il
faut il faut l'avoir à l'esprit et c'est
bien qu'on s'y mette et qu'on commence à
consulter je déplore un peu que la la
consultation ait lieu pendant les mois
d'été mais oui ça c'est la consultation
citoyenne qui ça aussi va permettre
d'embarquer la nation même si
c'est pas forcément la meilleure période
Marc le m'a dit vous qui regardez les
cartes les prévisions du GIEC une France
à 4 degrés alors c'est pas le scénario
le plus j'espère probable mais il est
possible c'est le plus pessimiste et
c'est vrai que pour la première fois le
ministre dit bah écoutez autant se
prémunir y compris du pire c'est quoi
plus 4 degrés c'est pas le c'est pas le
scénario le plus pessimiste c'est le
comme on dit c'est à dire que si on ne
fait rien voilà à quoi on pourra aboutir
et le GIEC d'ailleurs un scénario encore
plus
dur que celui là donc c'est un scénario
disons pas médian mais dans la moyenne
haute ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que j'allais dire
enfin enfin on prend un compte un
scénario réaliste puisque le plus 1,5
degrés prévu dans la corde de Paris en
France on peut l'oublier puisqu'on est
déjà un 8 degrés donc ce cet objectif
est inatteignable en tous les cas
l'horizon du milieu de milieu du siècle
pour le pour la France et à l'horizon
2050 on dépassera très certainement les
les deux degrés on sera plutôt autour de
2,5 qu'est-ce que ça veut dire déjà de 5
degré c'est à dire une chose sûre qu'on
qu'elle sera confronté dès 2050 pour
donner un chiffre qui je pense va parler
à tout le monde en 2022
côté exceptionnel par trois vagues de
chaleur une sécheresse record etc un des
été une des années d'ailleurs les plus
chaudes de l'histoire de l'humanité on a
eu on n'a pas beaucoup parlé 11000 morts
à partir de 3 degrés vous multipliez par
6 ça fait donc plus de 60 000 morts par
an il faut bien se rendre compte de ce
que ça veut dire on parlait tout à
l'heure d'érosion côtière et de
submersion marine il y a 1,5 millions de
Français qui sont directement concernés
par ces deux phénomènes ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir déplacer probablement
entre 300 400 500 communes qui sont dans
des zones de
exposées assez de risques là ça veut
dire des feux de forêt multipliés par 6
avec des mégafeux incontrôlables comme
on connaît en Espagne et au Portugal
aujourd'hui bref ça veut dire une France
assez largement invivable en particulier
je pense qu'on y avait tout à l'heure
mais en particulier pour les pour les
plus modestes parce que quand vous avez
les moyens vous pouvez vous déplacer
vous pouvez déménager dans des zones à
peu près préservées du réchauffement
climatique quand vous avez pas les
moyens que vous vivez dans un grand
ensemble dans un îlot de chaleur on l'a
dit des grands agglomérations vous êtes
coincé et là il y a véritable défi il y
a trois défis en fait il y a le défi
climatique il y a le défi social
c'est-à-dire comment on va faire pour
aider tous ces gens d'abord à s'adapter
et puis ensuite à changer leur
comportement leur mode de vie leur mode
d'habitat leur mode de transport etc et
puis le troisième défi c'est le défi
sanitaire c'est à dire que dans un pays
où vous avez des pointes à 50 degrés
vous avez trois mois de canicule par an
les personnes âgées les enfants les gens
qui travaillent en extérieur les gens
qui souffrent de maladie car usculaires
etc tout cela vont probablement être
victime pour beaucoup d'ennuis de santé
l'hôpital doit être armé pour ça et donc
ça veut dire que le défi à relever est
majeur alors pour terminer moi je trouve
un point très positif dans ce qui a été
présenté c'est que le gouvernement dit
enfin les mots pour parler du changement
climatique dans la première période du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron on disait
en gros je caricature un peu mais ça
l'idée c'est fantastique le changement
climatique on va faire muter notre
économie
va devenir les champions du monde et
donc ça c'est fantastique aujourd'hui on
dit plus ça et donc Christophe BECHU il
y a un vrai tournant dans le discours du
gouvernement en tous les cas de de
Christophe Béchu
ceci dit le grand point d'interrogation
c'est que tout ce qui a annoncé les
habits de borne j'ai vérifié avant de
venir dans la stratégie nationale bas
carbone y compris secteur par secteur
les objectifs qui étaient déjà donc il y
a rien de nouveau qui a été dit on nous
dit qu'il faut multiplier par deux la
vitesse du changement on ne dit pas
comment et on y dit pas qui va payer
alors qu'on sait que la facture
je veux juste vous montrer pour pour
qu'on prenne un petit peu voilà
l'extérieur l'exemple chacun s'y met on
a fait un magazine d'Hélène Bonduelle
sur les villes de demain voilà une
illustration où certaines écoles
parisiennes organisent des
îlots de fraîcheur où pourrait se
réfugier si effectivement et bien on
arrive à des scénarios insupportables
regardez
des plantes grimpantes des arbres des
copeaux sols et des structures en bois
la cour de cette école élémentaire a
bien changé
excite le bitume elle est devenue ce
qu'on appelle une cour oasis
[Musique]
là c'est beaucoup mieux
voilà tout le monde s'y met les villes
en surchaud c'est à retrouver sur sur
notre antenne François girolf les
économistes qu'ils ont longtemps parlé
de croissance verte pendant très
longtemps on a cru que l'innovation
allait nous permettre et bien de
contenir ce réchauffement voire même de
voilà de le dépasser ça c'est fini vous
vous êtes convertis maintenant ce qu'on
appelle la sobriété pour ne pas dire en
partie la décroissance je sais pas si je
peux parler au nom des économistes et de
la profession de tout entière mais en
tout cas c'est encore un débat au sein
de la profession des économistes et on
va dire que l'idée selon laquelle il
faudra décroître pour atteindre les
objectifs et prise de plus en plus au
sérieux il y a une grande conférence qui
a été organisée au niveau européen à ce
sujet et donc en tout cas ça c'est une
question ouverte alors que jusqu'ici
effectivement c'était plutôt considéré
comme une position assez hérétique chez
les économistes je pense que le débat
est pas totalement fermé on n'est pas
encore sûr parce que jusqu'ici c'est
vrai qu'on a réussi
à ni férié sur la croissance verte et on
a il entendre que les économistes sont
un peu pêchés par naïveté alors c'est
vrai qu'on a tendance notamment au
niveau européen a présenté la transition
écologique comme quelque chose de
forcément bien pour tout le monde ça va
créer des emplois ça va ça va nous
permettre d'être plus riche et puis ça
va être comme avant finalement les gens
voient bien que c'est pas le cas enfin
c'est à dire on voit on rentre dans le
dur de la transition on voit que ça va
coûter cher que ça va coûter cher un
petit peu à tout le monde et je pense
que c'est bien de rappeler ça parce que
ça permettra d'éviter des déconvenus ou
des ou des différences entre ce qu'on
dit aux gens et le et ce qui se passe
effectivement sur le terrain les gilets
jaunes par exemple évidemment avait été
cet exemple de ça où on avait dit bah
non la transition ça coûte rien puis
finalement on augmente le prix de
l'essence et les gens se rendent compte
que ça coûte bien quelque chose donc je
pense que c'est bien de rappeler que ça
va coûter cher et que et
qu'effectivement il faut même si il faut
souhaiter que ce soit le moins coûte
possible il faut se préparer à détendre
il y a une proposition de gens qui
disait différé on y vient mais déjà sur
le coup le rapport de cette économie dit
que c'est 250 à 300 milliards de dettes
en plus pour la transition écologique en
2030 et jusqu'à 34 milliards
d'investissements publics d'ici à 2030
ça tout le monde est à peu près
confronté au même au même efforts à
faire même si on n'a pas les mêmes
dettes la France avec ce qu'on connaît
de ces déficits et de sa dette elle a
les moyens de d'ouvrir ses
investissements là et cette dette je
vous avoue que moi je restais assez
keynésien dans l'approche c'est à dire
que je pense que du moment qu'on a des
objectifs qui sont bien définis le
financement en réalité rarement un
problème il y a énormément d'épargne en
France il suffit de la mobiliser de bien
l'orienter de ne plus orienter vers les
activités sales ou fossiles mais le
maître effectivement vers la transition
écologique mais je pense pas que le
sujet de l'épargne soit vraiment un
énorme sujet en revanche ce qui est vrai
c'est que ça va coûter cher et ça va
coûter cher à quelqu'un c'est pas
forcément d'ailleurs l'État qui qui va
payer
dans tous les cas quand on met des
contraintes par exemple sur les
logements en disant vous auriez plus le
droit de louer votre logement à partir
de 2028 si c'est F ou G clairement c'est
quelque chose qui va coûter très cher
aux propriétaires quand on dit à
quelqu'un on vous auriez plus de droit
de rouler avec cette voiture et vous
allez devoir en changer ça pèse sur la
personne qui adore changer sa voiture
donc ça va coûter cher comment on fait
en sorte que ce financement qui va
coûter cher donc on comprend soit le
plus équitable possible Jean Pisani
ferry fait une proposition
les riches doivent participer davantage
avec une taxation peut-être pas
forcément éternel mais en tout cas
transitoire qui permettrait de ramener 5
milliards d'euros par an à hauteur de
10% sur le patrimoine oui ou non parce
que il y a des sons de cloches
différents au sein du gouvernement
apparemment pierre Cazeneuve alors déjà
dire que jean-y ferriche l'estimation
des financements il y a aujourd'hui un
relatif consensus autour de ce que va
nous coûter aujourd'hui la transition
écologique ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que il évoque
plusieurs sources de financement de
l'endettement de nouveaux impôts du
refletage d'être public qui aujourd'hui
vont vers des énergies vont vers des
pardons des
entreprises moins vertueuses ou qu'on
appelle brune il y a tout un panel de
propositions aujourd'hui professionnel
et temporaire sur le patrimoine
financier des 10% de français les plus
aisés donc ça c'est une est-ce que c'est
pas le moment d'ouvrir cette porte là
que les plus riches d'entre nous
contribuent plus massivement au
financement de la transition écologique
je suis parfaitement d'accord après
je suis prêt à évidemment discuter c'est
un sujet qu'il faut mettre sur la table
je veux dire c'est une évidence bon
après il faut pas tomber dans le cliché
et dans l'incantation facile qui
derrière n'est pas réaliste c'est-à-dire
dire aujourd'hui on va taxer des
milliardaires d'un coup de crayon on va
faire un amendement pour taxer les
milliardaires et en fait ça va nous
sauver là on se met le doigt dans l'oeil
également parce que c'est une question
sociale aussi derrière la un vrai sujet
d'acceptabilité il y a un vrai sujet
d'équité de qui doit porter l'effort et
encore une fois je vous le dis
évidemment que les plus riches doivent
plus contribuer au changement au
financement de la transition climatique
par ailleurs parce que ça a été très
bien dit ce sont aussi des plus
précaires qui vont être en première
ligne des conséquences de changement
climatique mais derrière je fais
attention aux effets aux effets
d'annonce et on sait que derrière ce
n'est pas efficace et on n'arrive pas à
lever ces impôts là quand on parle des
très très hautes fortunes c'est souvent
du patrimoine qui est évidemment au sein
de leur des entreprises qu'il possède
donc il y a une dimension
constitutionnelle quand le président de
la République a supprimé l'impôt enfin
transformé pour être plus précis l'impôt
sur la fortune pour le faire peser
uniquement sur la fortune immobilière
c'est aussi parce que derrière on sait
que les conséquences c'est un retour
donc difficulté d'application mais vous
n'êtes pas complètement fermés dans le
débat public quelque chose de très
intéressant et comment on fait
contribuer les plus riches plus
massivement à la transition énergétique
et écologique et donc ça je le prends
mot et on le débat je suis sûr que vous
êtes d'accord avec plus de justice
fiscale pour financer je voudrais vous
montrer parce que ça touche aussi la
question sociale ce sujet d'Hélène
Bonduelle sur l'acceptabilité parce que
là on se projette sur le long terme on
parle de 2030 de 2050 voire de 2100 mais
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs villes il y a
beaucoup de résistance et il faut pas
remonter à la crise des gilets jaunes
pour s'en convaincre exemple la question
de la bétonisation ou des zones à faible
émission regarder revue de détails
signaient donc Hélène ponctuel
des lotissements des routes
inexorablement la ville gagne sur les
terres agricoles en 50 ans la France a
bétonné plus qu'en 500 ans on a le
pavillon on a de l'étalement urbain où
on a deux véhicules par foyer etc etc et
à cet égard en effet faut réussir à
revenir sur cette
catastrophe française qui a été
l'artificialisation des sols c'est pour
lutter contre cette artificialisation
des sols des astreuses pour
l'environnement que la loi climat de
2021 a tranché d'ici 2050 chaque mètre
carré pris sur les terres devrait être
compensées par l'équivalent rendu à la
nature c'est ce qu'on appelle le zan
zéro artificialisation nette un principe
simple mais une mise en oeuvre complexe
comment concilier par exemple le manque
de logement et des terrains devenus
inconstructibles des efforts trop
contraignants pour beaucoup d'élus
locaux sa fige les inégalités les
territoires qui sont beaucoup développés
pouvoir se développer les territoires
qui malheureusement ont pu connaître
même le déclin démographique ou
économique et bien elle on va figer ce
déclin et ça pose une vraie difficulté
les décrets d'applications ont
d'ailleurs été suspendus autre épine
dans le pied de la transition écologique
les ZFE zone à faible émission de
mobilité ces zones dans lesquelles petit
à petit les véhicules les plus polluants
ne pourront plus circuler 11 villes les
ont déjà mises en place d'ici 2025
toutes les métropoles de plus de 150 000
habitants doivent s'y conformer mais la
réalité n'est pas si simple et dans les
zones concernées les élus comme le
député Bruno milliennes ont bien du mal
à convaincre les automobilistes habitant
moi logement en appartement déjà j'ai
pas de prise donc tout ce qui est
électrique c'est impossible mes amis
c'est la même chose on en parle parce
qu'en fait ils disent on va peut-être
devoir quitter démissionner parce qu'on
ne pourra pas faire autrement quand on a
fait cette mission on a bien on a bien
eu conscience de de tous les freins
qu'il y a et de l'explosion sociale que
ça pouvait être plusieurs grandes villes
ont d'ailleurs revu leur calendrier de
mise en place de ces zones
des mesures environnementales
controversées retardé qui ne sont pas
sans rappeler le renoncement à la taxe
carbone de 2018 sur le principe du
pollueur payeur qui avait enflammé la
France et marquer le début de la
contestation des gilets jaunes
alors Isabelle Hugo qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à tous ces élus qui vous
supplient vous législateur de créer soit
des moratoires soi-même des des retours
en arrière sur ce que vous avez voté
notamment sur la bétonisation mais je
les comprends mais en fait le sujet
c'est que on dans la dernière
législature et même avant on a voté des
règles qui sont légitimes mais qui ne
sont pas accompagnés
si on veut penser de nouveaux modèles de
développement des villes par exemple moi
j'étais élu à l'urbanisme avant d'être
député et ben il faut les moyens parce
que rénover endancreuse rénovée dans du
patrimoine bâti c'est beaucoup plus
coûteux que d'aller construire sur un
terrain vierge qui par ailleurs et déjà
moins coûteux à l'achat et puis la
construction est beaucoup tombée dans
une crise de logement aussi aujourd'hui
extrêmement urgente le bâtiment peut
faire faillite donc les gens se disent
il faut pouvoir construire si c'est pas
possible là il y a pas une sorte de quoi
mais en fait il y a plein d'endroits où
construire il plein d'endroit où
construire aujourd'hui c'est juste que
il faut changer nos modèles de
développement il faut accompagner tout
ça on peut pas juste dire bon bah on
arrête on va pur artificialiser là et
puis débrouillez-vous c'est pas possible
donc faut aussi repenser la
métropolisation c'est un sujet il faut
aussi se dire que peut-être qu'on va
s'organiser autrement pour que il y ait
pas une hyperconcentration dans les
grandes villes regardez ce que ça ce à
quoi ça aboutit en Île-de-France c'est
un hyper étalement et on dit que
l'Île-de-France est très dense mais en
fait on a des anthropologistiques
jusqu'à 160 km dans autour de
l'Île-de-France et ça c'est l'étalement
de l'hyperconcentration de
l'Île-de-France donc si on continue la
métropolisation on va continuer à
artificialiser donc on peut continuer à
embarquer les citoyens sans
revivre des mouvements de colère en fait
ce qui est ce qui est ce qui ressort de
ces annonces de la ministre borne c'est
ça qui est incantatoire c'est qu'on
donne des objectifs mais on dit pas
comment on va accompagner les gens
normalement ça devrait revenir plus tard
aujourd'hui on a une prise
elle est quasiment plus mobiliser parce
que le reste à charge est trop important
pour les gens et on leur dit par contre
il faut il faut rénover votre logement
donc il y a plus que des gestes de
rénovation il y a plus il n'y a pas de
rénovation sur le court terme c'est vrai
qu'on est frappé bon il y a une crise de
l'inflation massive mais par tous ces
mouvements de résistance sur l'urbanisme
sur la question également des de l'eau
on voit la gare de l'eau avec la
question agricole et méga bassines etc
on est dans un moment comme ça où c'est
encore difficile de d'accepter ces
normes ces contraintes ou au contraire
on a changé d'air qui est très frappant
quand on regarde les tous les reportages
qui sont faits aujourd'hui par exemple
dans l'Allier ou des gens ont été
inondés hier ou avant-hier en Provence
des gens dans la maison a été incendiée
en Italie en Espagne au Portugal que
disent les gens les gens mais c'est
incroyable je viens de perdre ma maison
personne ne m'avait prévenu donc il y a
une responsabilité des politiques
étaient normes c'est-à-dire de dire la
vérité aux gens tout simplement pour
embarquer les citoyens il faut leur dire
qu'on est dans une situation d'urgence
encore une fois l'urgence climatique
tout le monde a ce mot-là à la bouche
personne ne dit concrètement ce que ça
veut dire ce que ça veut dire c'est que
1 on va pas vivre demain comme on vivait
aujourd'hui il va falloir changer notre
mode de vie et ça on peut pas le faire
au travers d'une démarche technocratique
telle que cette présentée aujourd'hui on
aligne des plans on fait des stratégies
bas carbone on fait des plans climats on
fait des lois énergie on fait des lois
résilience climat on accumule les textes
mais les citoyens eux tant qu'ils sont
pas touchés personnellement un n'y
comprennent pas grand chose et quand ils
le sont ils sont en colère parce qu'ils
ont l'impression que les politiques ils
ont pas prévenu donc aujourd'hui on est
un mouvement à un moment charnière ou
c'est pas Elisabeth borne ou c'est pas
Christophe déchu qui doit prendre la
parole ce sujet là c'est le président de
la République pour dire on est dans une
situation d'urgence on va tous vous
demander des efforts ça va coûter de
l'argent à tout le monde votre niveau de
vie va baisser probablement il va
falloir alors c'est pas les super riches
parce que j'ai compris c'est les gens
qui ont un patrimoine immobilier 500 000
puissance 1000 € de patrimoine
immobilier vous êtes propriétaire dans
une grande agglomération vous y êtes
donc ça va toucher des millions de
Français
d'habitation va augmenter bon donc il
faut dire la vérité c'est comme ça que
vous emmènerez les citoyens ce
gouvernement c'est vrai a pris un peu de
retard à l'allumage sur en tout cas il y
a ça il y a 5 ans sur la question de la
transition il est crédible aujourd'hui
vous avez le sentiment que il y a un
tournant non en tout cas il y a eu le
mérite de s'emparer de manière assez
claire et assez franche du sujet je
pense quand même temps l'opinion est en
train de vraiment d'évoluer il y a eu le
il y a eu l'été dernier qui a quand même
été un moment charnière je pense pour
beaucoup de Français et puis on voit
malgré tout que quand on demande des
efforts aux Français ils les font
regardez ce qui s'est passé
cet automne c'est divers avec la crainte
de ne plus avoir d'électricité mais
finalement les gens ont beaucoup moins
consommé donc je pense que petit à petit
les esprits sont commencés à être prêt
après ce qui nous attend est tellement
monstrueux que on ne sait pas si on
arrivera à franchir le pas et je trouve
que le mérite de ce soir c'est que quand
même beaucoup de choses très cash ont
été dites et que malgré tout petit à
petit ça infuse des esprits allez le mot
de la fin pierre Cazeneuve je suis 1000
fois d'accord et moi je trouve que c'est
le lien comme ça avec avec votre
prochain sujet c'est à dire qu'on a
beaucoup reproché au président de la
République de pas avoir assez agi pour
le climat et il y a quelqu'un qui s'est
converti hein il y a des tonnes de lois
qu'on a passé de tonnes d'action qu'on a
déjà mis en place et on voit aujourd'hui
quand elles sont confrontées confrontées
au principe de réalité quand elle
commence à s'appliquer que derrière on a
un frein et les mêmes qui nous disait
qu'on allait pas aussi assez loin hier
nous disent que maintenant on allait
trop vite donc c'est c'est très
compliqué de parler quand même de pause
sur l'évolution des normes européennes
pour le coup ça peut être un peu plus
que il faut arrêter de surréglementer
parce que sinon les entreprises n'ont
pas le temps et des suttants donc pas le
temps
c'est juste une pause réglementaire pour
que tout le monde puisse
s'affranchir déjà les objectifs qui sont
les digérer la contrainte actuelle du
financement vous l'avez dit c'est donc
on parlait des 10 % les plus riches mais
pour moi le sujet c'est surtout les
ultra-riches qu'on n'arrive jamais à
taxer parce que les 10 % les plus riches
c'est déjà eux qui produisent 75 % des
recettes fiscales donc c'est pour ça que
je veux que le débat soit posé le
principe d'efficacité de réalité et
enfin en tout cas on va suivre les
modalités concrètes c'est que l'enjeu
sur le financement on en a pas parlé
c'est évidemment la planification de ces
financements parce qu'aujourd'hui on
raisonne année par année et je pense
qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui d'une grande
loi de planification des financements de
la transition écologique à condition que
les différents présidents s'y tiennent
dans le temps merci beaucoup on va
s'arrêter là c'est évidemment vaste
chantier on va y revenir d'ailleurs au
moment des annonces plus concrètes merci
à vous d'être venu débattre vous restez
avec moi Ludovic vigogne dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties pris de
nos affranchis ce soir Richard Werly
relève les impasses de la loi de
militaire en débat dans l'hémicycle le
nouvelle histoire d'école avec Yanis
roder ce soir le menu halal servi dans
une école de Bordeaux qui fait polémique
et puis dans Bourbon Express d'Elsa
mondagaba comment la majorité repart à
la charge pour contrer la proposition de
l'iode sur les retraites mais d'abord on
plonge dans ces 100 jours est-ce a n s
je le disais qui ont été pour le moins
compliqué pour Emmanuel Macron fatigué
mal préparé limité le président loin de
savourer à la victoire triste alors
pourquoi que s'est-il passé on voit ça
dans l'invitation d'Emilie pertineaux et
on en parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Ludovic vigogne c'est
parce que vous avez radiographie le
départ raté du second quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est sans premier
jour depuis sa réélection ou plutôt ces
jours sans un long passage à vide dont
vous faites le récit inédit et très
détaillé vous décrivez un président
atteint de SUCCESS blues la victoire
semble lui avoir ôté toute motivation
pour la première fois Jupiter ne se
projette plus son entourage le trouve
fatigué vous parlez même de flottement
présidentiel vous Ludovic vigogne le
journaliste spécialiste de la droite
française pour le quotidien l'opinion
et auteur de plusieurs ouvrages sur les
arcades du pouvoir du quinquennat de
Nicolas Sarkozy à l'ambition de Gérald
Darmanin vous dévoilez notamment les
coulisses de la nomination d'Elizabeth
borne à Matignon car Emmanuel Macron est
d'abord séduit par Catherine Vautrin
femme de droite
ait la trottant et depuis samedi on a pu
assister à une levée de
boucle cette Catherine Vautrin contre le
mariage pour tous d'autres mettant en
avant un problème d'envergure
sera nommée à sa place une petite
défaite pour un président plus que
jamais au cœur des luttes de clan car
Ludovic vigogne vous révélez aussi les
jeux d'influence et la haine du chef de
l'État allait garder Philippe
entendre Édouard Philippe se définir
loyal mais libre comme il le faisait il
ne pouvait l'accepter cette inconnu qui
avait cessé de lettres quand il l'avait
propulsé à Matignon lui devait tout
votre ouvrage c'est donc le récit d'un
Élysée grouillant d'intrigue et d'un
Emmanuel Macron à la fois personnage
principal émetteur en scène alors
Ludovic vigogne Emmanuel Macron
saura-t-il se choisir un héritier
la réponse est non pourquoi d'abord
parce que c'est pas son il est pas fait
comme ça il a pas du tout l'intention de
choisir un héritier et puis d'abord et
ensuite il connaît l'histoire
c'est-à-dire que c'est très bien que ce
n'est pas François Mitterrand qui a
choisi que ce serait Lionel Jospin qui
reprendrait le PS et qui serait candidat
en 95 il laissera les ambitions se
dévorer les uns les autres et encore
moins Chirac qui a choisi Nicolas
Sarkozy et donc il laissera la nature se
faire c'est la vie des bêtes comme il
dit alors pour comprendre ce passage à
vite posterai élection ou rien n'était
prêt au tout flottait entre donc avril
2022 et puis l'été qui a suivi vous
convoquez la figure du coureur tchèque
Émile Zatopek c'est l'une des très très
nombreuses anecdotes qui fournit dans le
livre on va le voir c'est lui ce coureur
et racontez-nous l'anecdote c'est une
petite main au QG de campagne qui offre
au président un livre alors on est lors
de la première campagne présidentielle
on est en 2016 et c'est la fête de Noël
effectivement et chacun a dû piocher un
papier chacun des des collaborateurs des
gens de l'équipe de campagne a dû
piocher papier pour savoir à qui elle
allait offrir un cadeau pour la fête de
Noël et puis il y en a un qui a piocher
le nom d'Emmanuel Macron c'était un peu
moins facile de savoir ce qu'il allait
lui offrir et il choisit lui de lui
offrir le lit de Jean echnoz courir il y
a une allusion évidemment en marche etc
et effectivement ce récit de desnoses
raconte la vie des Mille Zatopek grand
coureurs qui a révolutionné sa
discipline mais qui a connu aussi une
fin de carrière difficile délicate et
qui est petit à petit sorti de
l'histoire et donc j'explique que c'est
qu'a vécu dès le soir de sa réélection
et dès les premiers jours qui ont suivi
Emmanuel Macron parce que ne pouvant se
représenter notamment en 2027 petit à
petit il s'est mis à un carnet le passé
immédiatement ce qui a été d'une cruauté
absolue voilà alors ce qui est très
intéressant c'est c'est cette
configuration institutionnelle pas de
mandats successifs le successif très
important Nicolas Sarkozy d'ailleurs il
tenait beaucoup c'est lui qui a fait
cette réforme constitutionnelle on
voudrait comprendre c'est cette
limitation qui rend ce flottement comme
ça possible ou c'est plus que ça c'est
psychologique une fois réélu ne pouvant
pas avoir de nouveaux combats électoral
il est bloqué comme comme un peu un peu
triste en fait c'est un flottement
humain qui repose sur plusieurs faits
qui qui va avoir des conséquences
politiques très lourdes qu'on constate
tous les jours aujourd'hui il y a
effectivement cette cette
impossibilité de se représenter Emmanuel
Macron pendant tout son premier
quinquennat était obsédé par sa
réélection
c'est ce qui fait courir un homme
politique la prochaine échéance et en
l'occurrence que le mandat soit ainsi
borné pour Emmanuel Macron c'est
effectivement quelque chose qui qui joue
psychologiquement ensuite il y a de la
fatigue physique il a été un hyper
président en première ligne durant 5 ans
et à un moment donné ça se paye surtout
que entre la guerre en
Ukraine la présidence française de
l'Union européenne et puis quand même un
peu la campagne il s'est beaucoup démené
ces dernières semaines
et ensuite il n'a absolument rien
préparé et c'est une forme d'erreur
voire même de fautes politiques alors il
va procrastiner il va laisser décanter
et il va même donner l'impression qu'on
décide à sa place racontez-nous comment
alors qu'il a choisi Catherine Vautrin
pour Matignon il va même déjà annoncé
qu'elle serait Premier ministre et ça
garde rapprochée va réussir à lui tordre
le bras non on peut dire Catherine
Vautrin a été première ministre 4 jours
puisque Elisabeth borne est nommé le 16
mai or le 12 mai le
Emmanuel Macron a reçu Catherine Vautrin
pour un long déjeuner dans le jardin de
l'Elysée pendant plus de trois heures
ils ont échangé sur la composition du
gouvernement la manière dont ils
allaient travailler ensemble le
directeur de cabinet de Catherine
Vautrin
quel serait son identité et à l'issue de
cette discussion vraiment Catherine
Vautrin se prépare elle va être la
première ministre et en fait dès que son
nom va fuer il va y avoir une formidable
rébellion du premier cercle de la
macronie l'aile gauche emmenait
notamment par Richard Ferrand qui
n'accepte pas que pour le troisième fois
Matignon revienne à un élève comme
Catherine Vautrin l'a été durant toute
sa carrière quelqu'un comme François
beroux ici se rebelle il estime que
Catherine Vautrin n'est pas aptop et
Jupiter exactement qui décide
normalement tout seul cèdes pourquoi
d'abord parce que les gens qui
s'opposent à la nomination de Catherine
de votre train sont les plus influents
autour de lui pèse lourd hein Richard
Ferrand c'est vraiment le fidèle et
village François Bayrou aussi est
quelqu'un qui qui pèse très lourd dans
le système et puis et puis finalement
Emmanuel Macron cette parce que au fond
tout le monde est un peu interchangeable
le système est tellement autocentré tout
était tellement verticalisé et remonte à
lui qu'après tout il se dit une première
ministre
issue du terrain venant de la droite ou
bien une première ministre réputée
techno venant de la gauche ça change pas
grand chose donc il aura pas la première
ministre qui s'était choisi et il n'aura
pas non plus son candidat au perchoir on
est à la Chaîne Parlementaire alors les
spectateurs veulent comprendre que dit
la victoire de Yaël Bron Pivet à la
Présidence de l'Assemblée est-ce que
c'est un désaveu direct pour Emmanuel
Macron oui parce que ce n'était pas sa
candidate des les heures qui suivent le
second tour des élections législatives
qui déception pour la macronie le camp
présidentiel Alexis colère notamment
choisi que le candidat aux perchoir pour
pour la macronie sera
pardon et et donc les rouages de la
majorité se mettent en place pour
inciter les députés à voter pour lui et
il y a une bombe pivée qui a décidé d'y
aller malgré le véto que lui a mis
l'Élysée quand elle a échangé avec avec
Alexis Kohler sur son envie d'être
candidate au perchoir va l'emporter les
Lisée ne sera pas suivi alors que même
Elisabeth borne a fait passer la
consigne qu'il fallait voter pour Roland
Lescure il y a des pages aussi
extraordinaires sur la relation Emmanuel
Macron Nicolas Sarkozy qu'il sait très
bien gérer
la même au téléphone le soir de de sa
victoire on comprend que voilà c'est
plus Emmanuel Macron qui joue avec
Nicolas Sarkozy et non l'inverse je
passe le temps nous est compté parlons
d'Edouard Philippe on va revoir cette
scène lors de la cérémonie d'investiture
le 7 mai 2022 regardez Emmanuel Macron
salut alors c'est plus qu'un salut il
touche on appelle ça la scène des Papous
le bras la joue la nuque et ça dure des
secondes et des secondes comment mettre
mal à l'aise quelqu'un qui n'est pas
tactile et doit Philippe cette scène
Edouard Philippe il va se la repasser en
boucle il ne l'a pas compris pendant
plusieurs jours il va se demander ce qui
a voulu lui signifier le président
nous-même on était très surpris de voir
Emmanuel Macron Édouard Philippe a avoir
une telle scène et on se demandait même
ce qu'il se disait en fait il se disent
que des banalités mais il y a
effectivement cette gestuelle du chef de
l'État on a l'impression qu'il veut lui
faire passer un message et Édouard et
Édouard Philippe va se demander ce qu'il
a voulu lui dire il a voulu le menacer
est-ce qu'il a voulu avoir un geste un
peu de sympathie est-ce qu'il a voulu
lui dire tu vois moi j'ai été élu deux
fois la prochaine fois si tu veux être
candidat en 2027 on verra bien si tu
réussis ça va beaucoup le turlupiner et
surtout que les mois précédents étaient
extrêmement tendu entre
on peut même dire que il y a de la haine
vous l'écrivez d'Emmanuel Macron le
maire Édouard il y a de la dégustation
le fin du bail la fin du bail de
d'Édouard Philippe à Matignon c'est mal
passé et manuel Macron l'a mal vécu
Édouard Philippe prenait trop la lumière
et puis ensuite ça a vraiment dégénéré
entre eux Emmanuel Macron c'est vraiment
beaucoup méfier de lui il a fait en
sorte que le mouvement que lancer
Édouard Philippe horizon ne se développe
pas et donc entre il a fait en sorte que
son entourage mitraille très
régulièrement son ancien Premier
ministre et donc il y a une montée de
l'attention une entre eux et Édouard
Philippe on a attiré toutes les
conséquences et désormais effectivement
il y a une extrême fraîcheur entre les
deux est-ce que vous diriez que à
l'heure où la page la crise de retraite
se tournent progressivement il a donné
aussi beaucoup d'interviews il est allé
au contact Emmanuel Macron il a contenu
ça dégringolade dans les dans les
sondages est-ce que le quinquennat
commence vraiment aujourd'hui non moi je
dis pas ça parce que Emmanuel Macron il
doit faire avec les fondamentaux qui ont
accompagné sa réélection et notamment le
fait qu'il est une majorité relative qui
complique au quotidien la vie de
l'exécutif et ce qui menace l'épaisseur
du bilan qu'aura Emmanuel Macron en 2027
donc même si il a donné là le sentiment
d'ouvrir une nouvelle séquence il ne
peut pas repartir à zéro parce qu'il y a
des composants qui sont tellement fortes
qu'elles écrivent qu'elle chaque action
qu'il entreprend qu'elle pèse sur chaque
action qu'il entreprit il est vraiment
obsédé par tout faire pour que Marine Le
Pen lui succède pas il sait très bien ce
serait une tâche sur ces 10 années au
pouvoir certains sénés qu'imaginent que
si elle était élu il pourrait mieux
revenir après
d'autres au sein de son entourage des
conseillers par exemple Jean-Pierre
Raffin qui lui explique qu'un mandat
réussit c'est une succession réussie et
que passer le flambeau à Marine Le Pen
ce serait terrible pour lui que les
images sur le perron l'Elysée le suivrai
et qu'on lui imputrait une partie de
l'élection de la candidat du
Rassemblement national d'un mot pour
terminer qui des trois alors ambitieux
il y en aura sans doute d'autres et
peut-être ce sera aucun des trois
Édouard Philippe Bruno Le Maire et
Gérald Darmanin vous les connaissez très
bien tous les trois qui le veut le plus
être président aujourd'hui Édouard
Philippe je pense que c'est celui qui se
prépare le plus d'abord parce que il est
il a la liberté pour le faire il n'est
pas au gouvernement donc il a le temps
de se structurer et puis c'est celui
quand même depuis quelques mois mais le
plus les choses en place pour pour le
devenir il a son parti il réfléchit il y
a de la France il travaille à son lien
avec les Français donc je pense
qu'aujourd'hui sur le papier c'est celui
qui le veut le plus revenez quand vous
voulez pour décrypter tout ça vous
l'avez compris les 100 jours chez
bouquins ça se dévore c'est sans doute
l'un des livres politiques les plus
instructifs et les mieux informés pour
comprendre cette première ratée année
ratée il faut bien le dire du président
de la République vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure des parties pris de nos
affranchis ils vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite
Richard Verly ce soir du quotidien
suisse bli qui Yanis roder professeur
d'histoire-géo en Seine-Saint-Denis
bonsoir les amis
directeur de l'observatoire de
l'éducation à la fondation de Jean
Jaurès installez-vous préparez blanche
parce qu'on commence par le bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nationale nous a raconté ce
soir par Elsa ou d'un gamin bonsoir Ce
soir je vous raconte l'histoire d'une
chronique que je ne voulais pas faire je
ne voulais pas parler de la proposition
de loi liotte celle vous savez qui
abroge la réforme des retraites pourquoi
j'ai rien contre ce texte mais il est
annoncé le 31 mai en commission des
affaires sociales le 8 juin dans
l'hémicycle c'est dans deux semaines et
l'idée c'est pas d'en faire une
chronique tous les soirs mais bien forcé
de constater que ce texte alimente la
chronique ici à l'Assemblée et donc en
toute logique bah il alimente ma
chronique nouveau rebondissement il y a
quelques heures c'est pas vraiment un
rebondissement parce que c'était annoncé
mais j'essaie de conserver votre
attention regardez on l'annonçait il y a
quelques heures sur notre site sur le
Twitter de la chaîne la majorité a en
bonne et due forme par la présidente de
la commission des affaires sociales
Fadil a katabi saisi le président de la
commission des finances pour juger de la
recevabilité financière de la
proposition de loi ou plutôt de son ni
recevabilité
ça y est c'est fait c'est officiel vous
avez saisi le président de la commission
des finances pour vous la proposition de
loi doit être jugée irrecevable en tout
cas j'attends son avis effectivement je
l'ai saisi ayant été moi-même
interpellés par de très nombreux députés
de la majorité présidentielle qui
effectivement se posait à juste titre la
question de la recevabilité il ne s'agit
pas d'une paille c'est il s'agit quand
même de plus de 20 milliards donc la
question se pose alors la recevabilité
financière on en a parlé c'est l'article
40 de la Constitution qui interdit à un
député et bien de faire une proposition
de loi ou un amendement qui crée une
charge financière pour l'État même pas
peur pour Charles de Courson rapporteur
liotte du texte puisqu'il a un atout
dans son jeu c'est le président de la
commission des finances Éric Coquerel
celui qui doit juger de cette
recevabilité écoutez Charles de course
vous avez plutôt de la chance puisque le
président de la commission des finances
Éric Coquerel il est plutôt favorable à
être proposition de loi c'est pas plutôt
vous pouvez retirer le plus tôt oui il
est il a dit publiquement c'est dire que
il est favorable mais c'est pas assez de
proposition de loi en tant que président
de la Commission de finances il applique
la jurisprudence constante de tous les
présidents de la commission des finances
qui n'ont jamais soulevé l'exception d'y
recevabilité financières pour aucune
proposition de loi donc vous l'entendez
pour les défenseurs de cette proposition
de loi il s'agit de préserver la liberté
d'initiative des parlementaires pour la
majorité le problème c'est Éric Coquerel
qui est parti alors est-il bon lui a
demandé la majorité dit c'est pas Éric
Coquerel président de la commission des
finances qui va la déclarer recevable
c'est Éric Coquerel le député LFI oui
alors faudrait que la majorité admettre
que le président de la commission des
finances et dans l'opposition et si un
président de la commission des finances
est dans l'opposition depuis 2009 c'est
qu'on estime que ça doit être un
contre-pouvoir par rapport à une
majorité qui peut estimer que parce
qu'elle est majoritaire à la raison
politiquement alors que va faire la
majorité on sent qu'il y a un peu
panique à bord là oui on nous parlait il
y a quelques jours de dédramatisation de
l'événement mais c'est bien tout
l'inverse qui se produit écoutez ce que
nous confiait en off un député de la
majorité on a été assez con pour en
faire nous-mêmes un monstre on leur a
fait une publicité de dingue c'est vrai
qu'on change de stratégie tous les jours
dans un premier temps l'idée c'est donc
de dénoncer la position des
ricoquerelles de demander l'avis du
rapporteur général du budget qui tient
et dans la majorité de supplier la
présidente de l'Assemblée Yaël brune
pivée de reconvoquer un bureau
maintenant on parle d'obstruction
déguisée de vote bloqué il y a un
dernier scénario qui circule j'ai même
hésité à vous en parler tellement il est
compliqué mais par conscience
professionnelle je vous le dis faire
tomber l'article phare de la proposition
de loi pour qu'il soit réintroduit par
amendement et là la présidente peut
outrepasser le président de la
commission des finances et le déclarer
irrecevable vous n'avez rien compris
peut-être mais si ça se passe comme ça
séance je vous l'aurais bien
explicitement d'un mot Ludovic on sent
bien qu'ils ne veulent pas aller au vote
le coût politique de perdre à votre sur
l'abrogation des 64 ans il est plus
grand pour la majorité que que de pas
avoir de vote du tout il est symbolique
mais je crois que malgré tout on
surestime quand même un tout petit peu
le poids de ce vote je crois que la page
la retraite elle est quand même petit à
petit en train de se tourner que la
mobilisation sociale elle est quand même
vraiment en train de redescendre et donc
je pense que même si la proposition de
loi était au final votée
on verra ça parce que elles a su ça pour
nous comme le lait sur le feu Richard
vous lui revenir sur la loi de
programmation militaire qui est en débat
actuellement à l'Assemblée on l'a dit
budget inédit 413 milliards d'euros mais
vous nous dites aussi c'est un débat sur
les handicaps stratégiques de la France
effectivement alors c'est toujours la
même histoire d'un côté il y a les
moyens de l'armée les fameux 413
milliards qui sont indispensables nous
dit-on pour se préparer à la guerre pour
protéger la paix et pour intervenir
militairement s'il le faut et de l'autre
il y a les réalités du monde que l'armée
française doit affronter et ses réalités
elle change et elle change malgré la loi
de programmation militaire il y a deux
éléments que quand même il faut
considérer parce qu'il concourt en ce
moment une relative impuissance de
l'armée française le premier c'est la
perte d'influence au Sahel est plus
globalement en Afrique alors vous savez
on se souvient en 2013 deux
interventions militaires réussites
d'abord au Mali puis en Centrafrique
c'était un peu l'apogée de la présence
militaire française et depuis tout à
dégringolé aujourd'hui même le plan G5
Sahel cher à la France il est à terre or
ce retrait il a un coup stratégique à
Washington par exemple les États-Unis
considéraient toujours que l'Afrique de
l'Ouest l'Afrique francophone c'était le
prix carré de la France les militaires
américains s'appuyaient sur un mail
française maintenant ça devient beaucoup
plus compliqué il y a la miniscrus
Wagner il y a un plan même de
transformer les campements français en
campement franco-africain bref il y a un
doute stratégique un deuxième problème
pour vous il est européen ce handicap
cette fois alors effectivement parce que
voter des crédits c'est une chose votez
beaucoup de crédit c'est encore mieux
mais ça ne règle pas une question qui
est celle de l'industrie de défense et
de son avenir parce que la France elle
veut garder à juste titre des géants
militarro industriels mais comment y
parvenir si on veut faire un avion du
futur le fameux avec l'Allemagne si on
veut mutualiser avec les alliés de
l'Union européenne parce que ça c'est
difficile de le faire sans perdre le
contrôle des usines et sans abandonner
un avantage technologique indispensable
aux forces armées la solution la France
la connaît elle l'a beaucoup employé
c'est exporter en dehors de France c'est
comme ça qu'on rentabilise les
investissements d'armement sauf que dans
ce cas on n'est pas tout à fait cohérent
avec la priorité militaire de la
souveraineté stratégique européenne
d'Emmanuel Macron bref sur l'Afrique et
sur la question industrielle la loi de
programmation militaire elle ne règle
pas au fond un problème c'est que pour
la France il faut qu'elle conserve cette
exception militaire et que ça a un coût
qui n'est pas seulement budgétaire merci
merci beaucoup Richard on va terminer
avec vous Yannis roder vous lire sur ce
collège de Bordeaux qui a proposé à la
cantine un menu halal une association de
parents d'élèves s'en est indignés ça
pose quel problème selon vous la
première question le premier problème
est bien sûr peut-on servir de la
nourriture confessionnelle dans les
écoles de la République de laïcité à
l'école du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale renvoie à une circulaire du 16
août 2011 du ministère de l'Intérieur
celle-ci dit qu'à côté de la règle
commune c'est à dire le repas commun
pour tous les services publics peuvent
éventuellement prendre en compte
l'appartenance religieuse d'un usager
pour proposer un repas différent mais
proposer à tous le même menu ce seul
menu comme ce fut le cas dans ce collège
je reviens à faire du dogme religieux de
quelques-uns la loi commune or celle-ci
ne peut être que la loi de la République
d'autre part depuis de 1905 la
République ne subventionne vous le savez
aucun culte utilisez de l'argent public
pour acheter des produits consacrés
religieusement me semble relever du
financement d'une pratique culturelle
donc il y a une entorse à la laïcité
selon vous mais il y a un autre problème
également oui l'école de République
insiste sur ce qui nous rassemble et non
sur ce qui nous divise proposé un repas
de nature confessionnelle c'est ouvrir
la porte au revendications particulières
c'est prendre le risque de diviser les
élèves et d'en mettre certains sous
pression par exemple qu'un élève dise à
un autre mais toi ceci tu dois manger
cela il existe donc un risque
d'assignation à résidence identitaire si
je peux le dire ainsi en totale
contradiction avec le principe de
laïcité qui s'appuie d'abord sur la
liberté de conscience et qui protège des
pressions éventuelles c'est aussi le
sens et on l'oublie parfois des lois de
1905 et de 2004 il y a un problème aussi
avec l'association parents que vous
vouliez soulever ce soir oui parce que
les parents qui ont alerté sont membres
d'une association proche d'Eric Zemmour
ce n'est pas un problème en soi mais ça
le devient s'ils sont les seuls pourquoi
d'autres associations de parents
d'élèves ou des organisations
enseignantes ne réagissent-elles pas le
risque devient alors me semble-t-il de
laisser la droite identitaire s'emparer
du principe de laïcité avec le danger de
transformer celui-ci en paravent d'un
discours bien éloigné en réalité de la
philosophie de la laïcité alors Yanis
roder infinie quel est votre avis sur
cette affaire je ne sais pas ce qui
motive Myriam le département et le
collège mais au-delà des atteintes au
principe de laïcité que j'ai évoqué je
pense qu'il se trompe car proposer des
repas confessionnels ne peut que créer à
un moment ou un autre des troubles et
des remous la preuve
pensez qu'agir ainsi serait anodin je
crois que c'est se mettre le doigt dans
l'oeil
c'est en réalité servir les radicaux
d'où qu'il vienne d'une part ce qui
tentent d'imposer au d'énormes
rigoristes aux Français musulmans et le
halal est un véritable stratégie
politique comme le rappelle très bien la
chercheuse Florence bergio black air et
d'autre part ceux qui instrumentalisent
la laïcité dans un combat identitaire
par conséquent qu'une connectivité
locale et qu'un établissement scolaire
servent la soupe si je peux ainsi à ces
gens quels qu'ils soient ne me semble ni
très malin ni très responsable vous
savez la laïcité c'est la condition de
la paix civile et comme le disait Jean
Zay un grand ministre du Front populaire
dans une circulaire de 1936 les écoles
doivent rester l'asile involables ou les
querelles des hommes ne pénètrent pas
c'est dit merci merci pour vos quatre
blanches la laïcité rien à rajouter à
défendre dans notre République bien sûr
merci les affranchis à très vite lisez
les 100 jours ou les jours sans
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est chez bouquin
signé Ludovic vigogne vous l'aurez
compris Elsa à très vite à demain
peut-être non sûrement avec plaisir
allez très belle soirée sur SCP soirée
documentaire qui commence maintenant
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain même
le même
[Musique]